I see a distant feature that I need to
appreciate Bob hello are you back hey
Bob wait is so drunk I am not that bad
I'm just a paid actor you have a dog
yeah I got a dog she's gonna help me
play minecraft good oh my god you're
still recording right Bob recording okay
good all right because I got all my
weight is so all right you guys ready
wait where's Bob wait get back here I'm
at the ticket booth late and hold her
it's okay you don't need to because this
is gonna be the conversation episode
apparently and you pour me to them Bobby
can you okay Bob you and I need to kill
a god Lexie's pause in my shirt
hang on okay we just wait what the hell
your head is stuck in the ceiling
Bobby are you seeing this what happened
Oh God good what's happening his head
was stuck in the ceiling okay never mind
you know what I don't even know Bob you
and I are gonna start this all right I'm
gonna play with one hand and hold my dog
with the other hand all right I'm here
the episode already recorded from the
pre thing okay anyway here we go you
guys ready
no get out of my mouth get out of my
mouth the joke you need the first joke
Oh get out here when I can only I can
only turn or move so oh I turned down my
volume Bob you and I need to catch up to
wait okay so get ready
look at the camera look at the camera
Lexi Lexi what happened we have a
special doggy select I talk Lexi just
gonna help ya
okay Bob get ready to drink okay wait
not you no wait you're gonna die okay
I'm ready to drink hi cheers everyone
shots oh all right
okay I'm out of coke now that was mostly
bourbon back oh okay this is a
markiplier world wait are you okay are
you gonna be able to hold it together
here okay this is market by world and
we're all gonna come in my mouth sticky
fingers to climb your teeth oh crap I
can't hit I'm using my right hand to
move and I can't hit W in the space key
at the same time she got me more drink
to drink that's good
I don't know if it's gonna be included
before this but this is my dog Lexi wait
no hang out that was supposed to I was
supposed to put music to that wait hang
on everyone get out there Bob
we Bob to come back come all the way
back outside no no right here it's gonna
be like this it's gonna be like hang on
wait I'm coming
no you can't hear right now but I'm
putting in music right now like in post
when I'm not drunk my spider-man powers
the music mark where are you I'm in the
Enter
where are you I'm I don't know Bob's in
the grass I didn't say go all the way
back goddamn it no I'm gonna play the
music again we should do an episode
about ballet okay you can go Alexey
she's really distressed that I'm holding
her on camera it's like The Lion King
[Music]
did the thing he said who teeny like the
job job okay no no no
Jawa that goes back to the first episode
of the very first that's what this
opposed to be it was supposed to be the
throwback episode that's right so I'm
not wearing my old skin of nothing you
have nothing you both had nothing at
that point man I was always Dexter what
I know you were like Steve you stand on
the [ __ ] plane do you dig is my thing
what is your what your dick is my thing
mine or Bob's oh I think it's our
collective dick alright hey guys welcome
back and why it is this episode started
10 minutes ago wait where are you think
I'm hammered where are you I'm in the
casino trying to get Barry losing I'm
working they're gonna think I've been
drinking a lot are hammered but we need
to focus on ears the fact that the first
episode ever featured a sand castle
focus on is I was making one
first episode was it well that's the one
you were digging in the sand and then
mark was digging in the sand and then Oh
Castle out of sand it's a sand castle
you dick I remember that when I found
the Jojo aah Oh No oh we should we
should make reaction videos of the three
of us watching our previous videos would
that be entertaining everyone would that
be entertaining to watch no I thought
yes no my hands are up oh my god pushes
our keys in the keyboard wait hang on
okay we need to go through this theme
park I need to drink a lot more hey guys
guys I found something where are you how
was dinner I have to show you this wait
wait come back I heard a voice that's
good towards the casino where's mark
I'm outside the casino come down here
come down here mark where you at okay go
in the front entrance of the casino I
found a wait let's wait for Mark to get
here because I'm visible I don't see you
oh I see your foot scuffs yeah you're
invisible dude dude anyway anyway no
come here I got to show you this thing
are you ready Wayne so drunk so quickly
I know I'd leave what's going on with
mark
anyway let's try to drink when you
[Laughter]
what's the next episode
right now we're all of you oh this is a
theme park you guys are laughing I can't
stop I can't drop my inventory what's
going on Lorca's a zombie can I get food
cake over here this cake or all in need
he's like he's like Oprah but it's got
more hair oh he's got more hair than
different there's actually a statue of
Slenderman that's actually done well
of there hang on we won we need to be
able to fly my craft all the time
mark stop your fearless leader you
really have to stop a cheeks hurt so
much mark yet stop Bob you're trying to
say is you need to catch up man I'm dude
I've had about a third of a bottle of
bourbon right now but it sounds like
ounces okay all right I'm done I'm done
don't make me kill half again okay so
work why did I just get poured in here I
need a lot of pink wool I want to put
nipples on this [ __ ]
Oh God in the Slenderman I still can't
even fly I want something just like it
put next to it so I'm just gonna go out
on a limb and guess that this is not a
copy of the Slenderman that we made Oh
watch this I'm gonna fly all the way up
in the air and turn fly off ha I can't
how do you turn fly on
and hindsight was a bad idea okay Ari
I'm done I'm done okay all right so
let's go to the roller coaster guys and
this one we're gonna show off the theme
park no oh no you just balloon up here
has your face on it
hey I can fly you the freakin miracle
well why is there a bunch of oh it's
just tentacles Wow
hey this slender said she is really good
yeah you know it doesn't look like it
doesn't look like a horse at all I'm
teleporting you wait I'm trusting you on
this one I'm on to helping your pair
can't get any weirder a giant waterslide
yeah there's a giant waterslide yeah I'm
so take you from up here you can see
everything in the park
no [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
ow okay the top of the waterslide makes
me hit my head fairly I'm too tall
just like that was not even funny
laughing about I honestly don't even
know
we apologize on behalf of the one and
only mark scream there's like a monkey
in his room
holy crap homework while you watch I've
done it don't
only you can prevent forest because I
can't
censor that sorry I got it I gotta edit
these sober cuz oh where am I now why do
you have oh I'm here - I don't know
where you oh there you are home right
here oh okay I'm done buying gun
laughing I don't know what's going on
with me but I I cannot hear I'll push
you I'm out of here [ __ ] it's like
randomly I'll suddenly start laughing
and I can't stop you don't laugh I can't
I kiss I'm gonna ride this a drink all
right okay that's a good idea
there's the Marcus Fink's the mark amid
a market coasters as the more sketball
course oh okay hey there's fireworks
bourbon in your nose oh god it hurts
Wow Bob you're drinking it though
laughing while I'm trying to drink okay
stop laughing I think I'm good for now
but I'm I think we all need stronger
drinks that's not the truth
you're not drinking it out they don't
say that anywhere they might say that in
Russia I don't know did Steve tell you
that who is Steve baby Wonder a Miss
Steve anyway anyone named Steve Stevie
Wonder oh god Steve was cool I don't
know anyone named Steve we graduated
with us Steve what
Oh morning I did go to school no no I
don't go to school I spend all my time
doing nothing like that Seinfeld episode
at all in a person what all right what's
next on our agenda holy crap the
minecarts going backwards
[Laughter]
Oh goddamnit I'm going backwards now
[ __ ] it you know what this episode I'm
[ __ ] done I'm done
I'm not doing it anymore I'm I've done
pocket it's been awesome as always I'm
dead I'm trapped in the fence Wade how
about you go suck ten dicks because the
record is for what is the world record
for number of dicks sucked I really
wonder what is the record is it in the
Guinness Book
like how many like is there a record for
it like I know there's a record for how
many cigarettes you smoke at once is
there a record for like how many dicks
you smoke at once I just typed something
into a message no mark just no
[Music]
no don't stop how actually drunk are you
mark are you where it seems like you are
[Laughter]
be is it ready